Bonjour, ici c'est Steve Kauffman.
Pour ceux qui connaissent ma chaine ici à Youtube,
j'aime bien apprendre les langues, j'aime bien en parler dans mes vidéos.
Si vous aimez ma chaine veuillez vous abonner,
cliquez sur la cloche pour avoir des notifications.
Aujourd'hui je veux parler de "l'écoute" dans l'apprentissage des langues,
parce que pour moi, c'est, disons, "la tache" dans l'apprentissage des langues.
Et pour ceux qui ne me connaissent pas
j'en suis à ma 19ème et 20ème  langues, c'est à dire, l'Arabe et le Persan.
Ce que je fais plus qu'autre chose c'est "écouter"
"L'écoute".
L'écoute pour moi c'est l'outil, c'est l'arme essentielle dans la conquête des nouvelles langues.
Pourquoi?
D'abords, parce que c'est très facile à faire.
Je le fais le matin quand je me lève, je fais des exercices,
le matin j'écoute la langue.
Je prépare le petit déjeuner, j'écoute la langue que je suis entrain d'apprendre.
Si je suis dans ma voiture, si je fais d'autres taches, je nettoie la maison ou quoique
ce soit, je peux toujours écouter, et ça n'a jamais été plus facile.
Je peux télécharger des contenus d'internet, des livres sonores, des podcasts, des
vidéos de Netflix, de Youtube.. n'importe quoi, et j'écoute!
Donc, l'écoute, ça commence.. C'est le premier pas.
Parce qu’en écoutant, il y a des choses que je ne vais pas comprendre,
là, je vais vouloir lire parce que je n’ai pas compris
et là je lis, parce que j'ai une application qui s'appelle lingQ.
Donc j'utilise, le plus souvent, l’iPad ou bien le téléphone, l’iPhone pour travailler ce texte,
parce que j'écoute toujours des choses, où j'ai un texte, où j'ai la possibilité de comprendre.
Si on écoute, et on écoute, et on comprend jamais rien, ça n'aide pas beaucoup.
Donc, ce qu'il faut c'est travailler le texte, chercher les mots et les expressions
ncomprises, chercher les explications, relire, écouter de nouveau.
Donc, c'est ce genre de processus qui m'emmène d'un niveau débutant jusqu'à un niveau
où je peux sans difficulté écouter des podcasts politiques, suivre des films Netflix ou ailleurs…
Et c'est un processus assez long et à chaque étape
c'est à l'écoute que je passe 75% de mon temps en apprenant une langue.
Mais, quand j'écoute, il n'est pas possible pour moi de me concentrer tout le temps.
Donc, il y a quelque chose dans l'écoute qu'il faut savoir.
Quand on a une certaine expérience dans l'apprentissage des langues,
on sait qu'il y aura toujours des choses qu'on ne comprend pas.
On ne peut pas totalement se concentrer, on ne doit pas vouloir ou exiger de soi-même
qu'on puisse tout comprendre, ce n’est pas possible, ni qu'on puisse toujours se concentrer.
Si j'écoute quelque chose dans la voiture en m'exerçant le matin.
Si j'écoute pendant 15 minutes, peut-être, qu’il y aura là, selon ce que je suis en train de faire,
il y aura 20% du temps où je vais me concentrer, 50% du temps..
Mais, peu importe, parce que de toute façon, surtout quand on est entrain de se concentrer
et même si on n’est pas en train de se concentrer, la langue entre dans le cerveau
et ça nous permet de s'accoutumer à une autre langue;
le rythme, l'intonation, les expressions, le choix des mots,
enfin, toutes ces choses-là qui sont tellement importantes.
Donc, l'écoute c'est non seulement le moyen ou l'activité qui est la plus facile,
du moins dans mon cas, où je passe la plupart de mon temps,
mais c'est aussi le but!
Parce que pour moi la compréhension orale, c'est la chose la plus importante.
C'est la première, disons, «étape».
Si l'on peut bien comprendre ce que dit l'autre, ce que l'on raconte dans des films, dans des podcasts,
ça nous donne une espèce de base qui va nous permettre de nous exprimer dans cette langue.
Parce que là on peut s'engager dans des discussions, des conversations avec des gens qui parlent bien la langue
et on va comprendre ce que eux ils disent
et si on n’a pas ce niveau de compréhension orale
on ne pourra pas participer à ce genre de conversations,
on ne pourra pas tirer profit des films parce que on ne comprend pas.
Mais, dès qu'on comprend, par exemple dans le cas des films ou des séries Netflix ou n'importe quoi.
Si on comprend, 75-80%, la plupart de ce qu'ils racontaient dans ces films.
On peut en tirer profit et on va s'améliorer et on va améliorer son niveau dans la langue,
puisqu’on a déjà un certain niveau de compréhension.
Mais il faut travailler ce niveau de compréhension, donc il faut écouter.
Écouter et travailler les textes
pour que ce qu'on écoute devienne de plus en plus compréhensible
Bon, Une autre chose...
On ne peut pas, c'est à dire si moi je commence une langue comme j'avais fait pour l'Arabe, le Persan, le Grec, le Roumain.
Au début, c'est du bruit, je ne comprends rien!
Mais j'écoute des choses assez brèves et je cherche des mots et des expressions dans lingQ là et je lis
et je réécoute et relis, et ça continue comme ça. Mais je ne vais pas…
Et finalement, à la fin, je vais écouter la même chose.
Parce qu’on a par exemple à lingQ, les mini-stories,
qu'on appelle les petites histoires avec beaucoup de répétitions.
Bah, je vais écouter la même histoire en Arabe 30 fois.
Mais pas 30 fois à la fois, c'est ça qui est important.
Je vais écouter la première histoire, la deuxième, la troisième, la cinquième..
Puis je vais réécouter, retravailler la première puis la 2ème, 3ème, 4ème, 5ème, 6ème, 7ème
et ensuite, la première..
De cette façon là, on va avoir assez de répétitions, mais sans que ça devienne,
ce qu'on appelle en anglais "The block learning".
On peut pas dire, je vais complètement maitriser ce contenu, ce n'est pas possible.
Il faut donner au cerveau la possibilité de se balader un petit peu,
pas trop essayer de forcer la chose.
Parce que plus on écoute ou on lit la même chose à maintes reprises, moins on apprend.
C'est parce que, comme dit le fameux Neuroscientist Allemand Manfred Spitzer:
"Le cerveau a besoin de répétition mais de nouveauté".
Il ne faut pas donner uniquement au cerveau rien que de la répétition.
Il faut aussi donner de la nouveauté, le cerveau veut des choses nouvelles.
Donc, il faut ménager un peu le contenu qu'on est entrain d'écouter
une fois qu'on est arrivé à un certain niveau
où on comprend des podcasts politiques, et on ne manque que 10% des mots.
Alors, là, pas la peine d'écouter tellement de fois.
Parce que, la plupart du contenu là, on l’a compris.
Mais au début quand on a compris que 10, 15, 20% et qu’il faut lire et ensuite réécouter etc..
Alors là, il faut écouter beaucoup de fois, mais pas à la fois, c’est ça qui est important.
Bon, qu’est ce qu’il y avait encore à dire,
Il ne faut pas trop essayer de maitriser, il ne faut pas être frustré quand on ne comprend pas,
il ne faut pas être frustré si on est incapable de se concentrer.
Par ailleurs, je suis..
pour moi c’est plus facile de se concentrer si je suis entrain de faire autre chose à la fois,
alors que si je m’assoie et je vais essayer d’écouter, rien faire que d’écouter.
Alors là, je vais avoir davantage de difficulté à me concentrer.
Mais si je fais autre chose, je laisse mon esprit se balader,
je me concentre de temps en temps, puis ensuite je ne me concentre pas.
Mais ce faisant, je trouve que la 20ème fois que j’écoute quelque chose
je vais m’apercevoir d’une chose que je n’avais pas observé avant.
Oui, parce que d’autres choses sont devenues évidentes,
mais là, une chose, une structure dans la langue, une prononciation,
un choix de mot que je n’avais pas noté,
tout d’un coup ça devient
pour moi évident et donc j’assimile ce nouveau phénomène dans la langue
et c’est ça l’avantage de l’écoute à maintes reprises, de la même chose,
mais pas à la fois.
Alors qu’une fois qu’on est déjà plus avancé, alors là, j’écoute pour le plaisir,
j’écoute pour le plaisir d’un… J’écoute pour le plaisir un audio livre, un livre sonore de la littérature etc..
dans les langues ou je suis plus avancé.
Mais de toute façon l’écoute… L’écoute disons, «organisée» d’une façon intelligente et réaliste,
je crois que c’est l’activité la plus importante dans l’acquisition des langues,
bien sûr, ça va avec, quand même, la lecture, l’opportunité et l’occasion de parler
et éventuellement d’écrire dans la langue.
Mais l’écoute c’est quand même, pour moi,
ce qu’il y a de plus important dans l’acquisition ou l’apprentissage des langues
et c’est aussi un but!
Parce que l’écoute ça veut dire la compréhension orale.
Merci beaucoup!
Donc j’ai fais cette vidéo en Français, la plupart du temps je parle en Anglais,
parce que la plupart des gens qui suivent ma chaine ils parlent mieux l’Anglais que le Français.
Et toutes les vidéo que je fais ici sont importées, sont disponibles comme leçons à lingQ.
Donc je préfère quand même puisque je ne suis pas natif en Français.
Il est mieux donc d’étudier et d’apprendre à partir de personnes qui sont natives de la langue.
Donc, j’hésite à faire des vidéos en Français qui deviendront donc des leçons à lingQ.
Mais je parle aussi dans d’autres langues de temps en temps.
J’ai fais un vidéo avec un autre Steve
qui parle Japonais mais d’une façon absolument incroyable et impressionnante,
je laisserai le lien pour ceux qui s'intéressent au japonais
Et ils pourront m’entendre discuter avec cet autre Steve, un Américain d’ailleurs, en Japonais.
Voilà! Merci beaucoup pour votre «écoute»!
Au revoir!